at any point in time we are continuously
being encouraged to pick up some novel
or other reviews the recommendations of
friends and the windows of bookstores
edges towards certain titles that were
promised will definitively answer the
deepest needs that we bring to
literature imagine that we have picked
up such a title it's late in the evening
and we're just starting out of volume
releasing the characteristic sweet smell
of a newly open world the author is
going to great lengths to get us
interested in the life of someone living
in Edinburgh in the 1930s it's raining a
lot and their car breaks down they've
got a friend in Budapest who is pregnant
there's a robbery at a department store
there's a reference to Dundas Street and
we flick back 30 pages and realize
that's where the main characters sister
used to live there's a retired engineer
with very bushy eyebrows who must be
important in some way we don't know yet
immense effort and intelligence are
being devoted to exploring the existence
of a fictional individual but at this
point an incidental yet rather major
thought might strike us no one we
realise has ever looked at our life our
habits our friends our past our dilemmas
and problems with such sustained
curiosity or in such detail in the novel
on our lap there seem to be plenty of
pithy insights clever summations
striking observations and astute
analyses but all for the sake of the
workings of the mind of someone else
who's not really very much like us it's
a familiar situation that we have been
educated politely to take for granted
but now it might hit us a particular
force we're reading the wrong book what
we should really be doing is reading a
book about us written with the same
elegance and wisdom but placing the raw
material of our life in a lucid order
selecting and joining up diverse events
in our chaotic stream of consciousness
and turning them into a coherent story
we are politely interested in the
stories of others but the story we
really need to hear about is our own
what we really crave is for someone to
make loving sense of us we want them to
write us with all our complexity and
obscurity down in crisply phrased and
clear sentences our reading of someone
else's novel is dutiful and
well-educated no doubt but it's as if we
went to the doctor and they made a very
accurate diagnosis of someone else's
earache or if a financial adviser went
to great lengths to present us with a
solution to the money troubles of a
stranger from which we could at best
extract the occasional fleeting hint for
what might possibly be useful in our own
case in the 1690s one of the greatest of
French writers for suave vanilla was
appointed tutor to the young Duke of
Burgundy to assist with his education
vanilla wrote a long and fascinating
novel called The Adventures of
Telemachus
in which the Duke lightly disguised was
the central character the problems the
character in the novel faces were
exactly the problems the Duke was
actually facing the strengths and
weakness of a central character
carefully understood by the writer were
his it sounded like the rarest and most
cultivated luxury to have someone write
a novel about you but it's a treat we
should in a sense all be granted and
perhaps secretly crave we don't need to
give up our jobs and become writers
because this book of ourselves is one
we're writing already we're at work on
it in the early hours when we can't
sleep when we daydream make plans go
over the past and give ourselves over to
retelling as best as we can what's
really happened to us and what it could
all mean it's simply a pity we don't
devote as much energy as we should to
this emerging critically important work
it is hugely noble that we spend so much
time reading the novels of others it is
life-saving and properly generous to
ourselves when we learn to order and
make sense of the experiences of our own
trouble days and nights there is no risk
in reading plenty of novels but on a
regular basis we should carve the time
to write and then read back to ourselves
the nascent unfolding novel of the story
of our own lives to learn more about
self-knowledge click the link on your
screen now
you